even I don't feel me are they don't be
on me don't do it okay
I'm excited for them to see what condoms
African people who are self-determining
women living in their power please what
a time for black times that to come out
it's why it's bringing people together
people gonna go see it together
hopefully dress up when they do it this
is a part of Black History there now
where are you gonna go oh my god okay
this movie is full of incredibly
talented actors and we have legends like
Forrest Whitaker
Angela Bassett and then we have
newcomers like the Tichenor right and
Daniel Kahlua and they're badasses we
have big meals together we went to this
African restaurant more than once and
you just took it took it over
we enjoyed spending time together on and
off set we had like a six-week boot camp
and we'd have like a group session with
all the doormen lodging and then we'd
break off and learn our individual
skills it was really tough on the body
but also really cool because the more I
exerted physically the more I felt like
I was getting into the Nakia zone of it
all I lost one puppy my skincare routine
well I'm a low maintenance kind of
person stay hydrated and then I use a
light moisturizer Lancome day cream
that's known as energy de vie I try and
not wear makeup when I don't need it and
then I'm very religious about taking my
makeup off avocado oil to take off my
makeup because it's gentle okay what do
I have here I love to play oven and
that's one point
bye-bye-bye oh now you're back now
you're back oh okay who's gonna win it
and then now you want to get in the
midst all right come on come on we got
it who's got it
[Music]